what's up everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder i just got off
a plane and i got off the plane to a ton
of dms tweets you name it not on
instagram because apparently instagram
and facebook were down for a bit but on
twitter about some guys that have proved
that the andrew garfield leaked video
and leaked photo is actually real now
this is coming from
corridor crew they have 5.11
million subscribers and apparently they
are vfx guys so i'm gonna go ahead and
react to this i haven't actually seen it
yet so
they claim that they can prove that it's
real because they know what they're
doing and they can tell a deep fake from
an actual one
uh everybody's been telling me to check
this out so we're gonna go ahead and
check it out right now see what they
have to say um
there's little doubt in my mind that
right right now that this is fake um
i don't think this is fake at all i
think it's 100 real um i think i i think
it was released on purpose like in all
honesty um i i think it might have been
slipped through just to get everybody
excited and get marketing up a little
bit but anyways we're gonna we're gonna
check this out and see what they come up
with here we go so sam and i are gonna
cut through that conflicting information
today we're gonna break down the video
break down by pixel determines
authenticity is it possible that the
shot was faked or is it real so come
with us through the critical thinking
process these guys are like next time
something like this happens legitimate
videographers guys
so they know so what's interesting is
that it looks like this is an actual
cinema camera or a rather high quality
camera it's a large sensor because you
can see some depth of field here this
isn't like some person on their phone
makes sense either it's like it is
pretty clear from a behind-the-scenes
crew or someone who has like tapped into
one of the actual monitors on set this
could just be footage from when he was
filming spider-man and he's just talking
to a stunt double like do you want me to
stand like you were standing like this
photo all right so we can bring that
footage like that original footage from
the amazing spider-man there's a pretty
big difference between the two his
hairdo is obviously a lot younger he
looks like he's in high school but his
hairs like they wouldn't just have a
different very different no
yeah this hair is different it's
definitely footage different footage his
face looks like it's a different
resolution from his costume slightly
blurrier there does seem to be a slight
lack of detail there it's a bit of an
anomaly in my opinion because if we're
looking at like the bars there we can
see like surface look how clear that is
and it does seem like there's a slight
lack of quality on the face that being
said like generally if you upload a
video to a social media platform the
chance is that it's a resolution mp4
file yeah it's it's pretty likely and
the way mp4 files work is by compressing
motion
into an overall image so it's less about
rendering an unique frame every single
frame but taking
one frame and then basically saying all
right this is the direction the pixels
are moving so that way we have motion
data instead of image data it's called
iframes
and everyone so try
to upload videos
clip everything that's not moving is
going to stay in crisp right
moving will happen obviously okay yeah
the main claim i've seen made about this
video is that we are in fact looking at
a deep fake of andrew garfield i don't
think this is a deep fake this would be
the best deep fake event that's what i
said it would be the best ever
i mean the best defense i've ever seen
is the tom cruise deep fakes oh it's tom
cruise
tom cruise by chris
chris
you can tell the deep fix if you
scrutinize it you can see there's no
crystal shadow under the nose
there's a bit of a sense of like his
face is being lit and then like re-lit
again okay i feel
uh
fresh all right we're all learning right
now
so we can learn
for future purposes
you can see it feels a little bit like
it's a flat texture of a face you know
as opposed to like a three-dimensional
object so that's because the computer is
trained on a bunch of images of a face
well those images are filmed at all
different focal lengths you know
oftentimes if you're doing say you know
training from movies like let's say
we're doing a tom cruise deep fake and
you're grabbing all these tom cruise
shots so a lot of times you're using
close-ups close-ups are often shot with
a telephoto lens and what a telephoto
lens does is it tends to flatten
everything so my face has a lot of
distortion right my nose is scaled up a
little bit because it's closer to you my
ears my face is probably kind of like
and these get a little bit smaller yeah
perspective interesting face
now you'll kind of see how everything's
flattened on my face and you've probably
seen like the gifs of this on reddit or
something like that like look at what
lenses do to the face what ends up
happening is that when you put a deep
thick kind of face you kind of get this
weird like flat nose effect or like the
whole face is almost like this like
squished lack of perspective almost like
orthographic view when in real life
should actually be getting a lot more
perspective and depth and almost like
vanishing points representing themselves
on the face as the geometry moves around
it's really really really really good
but just scrutinize it it's not quite
right that mind let's go back to andy's
first thing i'm seeing is there's an
edge light coming from the top right
corner kind of first
daylight blue edge light hitting the
lines on his costume it's also hitting
the side of his neck at the corner of
his jaw and his hair here
uh a little bit of the corner of the jaw
catching the light okay so the lighting
that specific kind of sharp lighting
detail that's something a deep fake does
not do very well most deep fakes cover
this part of the face yeah
that makes perfect sense but they get
the lighting gave it away low resolution
so that would mean that the head has to
be real he almost never deep fake hair
it's very very hard to do especially
especially
hair like that
garfield another thing to look at is the
eyes so your eyes are reflective they're
spheres the reflections okay eyes should
be consistent with each other if one eye
shows one light reflection the other eye
shows two light reflections well then
that's a sign that the eyes are being
faked and deeply
you can see the glistening light on the
water
and it's consistent the d-fake might
catch that here and there but it has no
idea of what's causing highlights or
light it just knows statistically where
these things go you'd have to have so
much very specific
data of andrew garfield's tongue with
light glistening on it he had the
correct color temperature angle to be
able to replicate it here no one i mean
maybe somebody's just thought it'd be a
funny joke to to fake this i mean there
are good deep fake artists out there
that couldn't hear up you do something
like this yeah well as real as this
looks
it has been revealed that this shot is a
defeat
yeah right oh now they're trying to tell
this is fake
yeah the puppet tool
you can tell
try
never why would you move it
is fake
and the guy already said it's amelia's
sake so we don't have to worry about
that see how the track
but they could tell immediately it's
fake that's so funny alex serrato is
trolling all of us he's even come out
and said as much on his youtube channel
all right so the
baby the number of news articles that
went out saying it turns out oh it turns
out
after all they just point to this it's
like all they had to do was show the
training shot to one person who's ever
done a deep fake in their life and they
would
there is one thing about this that
caught me than that's weird when he
enhances the face
and it's the way his teeth jump around
when it's enhanced here so what's
happening here is he's using an ai up
resin algorithm here that's looking at
the face and it's analyzing detail and
filling in extra detail and so the
reason the wrinkles are moving on the
lips or the way the teeth the heights
are shifting is it's identifying
patterns and it's guessing yeah maybe
this is the top of the tooth and then a
few frames later no this is the top of
the tooth and so the tooth constantly
jumps around all the details are not
temporally consistent as we would say
now in a real deep fake this is
something you would actually run into
you would run into the teeth shimmying
around you run into the rainbow oh
that's where you're shimming around a
little bit all right so this video is
fake but are there any other ways one
could fake this video without using this
video this could be andrew garfield cut
out from a film and they set up the shot
to like look like it that's how i would
fake it like i would find a shotgun
field where i can measure the lighting
and like the motions and i just cut it
out and stick it onto my footage you get
pretty close i mean here's the thing at
the end of the day could this be faked
yes this could be faked it would be
very very very very very good very good
fakery i don't think it's a deep fake
deep fakes are not magic they're really
not that crazy they require a ton of
artistry to actually blend and look real
also it's probably not even a leak like
at this point if i was a movie studio
what's going to get more that's
literally what i opened this video to
say or a leaked one you tell me i'm not
supposed to see this right yeah you know
it's like it's like i'm totally clicking
on that yeah i mean they just got us to
talk about this exactly and now i'm
talking about their video talking about
it and how many videos have i done
talking about it i mean
i wouldn't be surprised if that sony's
plan um if it wasn't and it wasn't
supposed to get out sorry
to be fair i didn't talk about it till
everybody else started like talking
about it i definitely didn't show it
until like everybody had seen it but
these guys seem to know what they're
talking about apparently they have
really good credentials um and they have
5.11 million subscribers
so that's that's that's pretty good they
say they don't think it's deep faked and
they say that if it's faked in any way
it would take so much to do which i
think if somebody's trying to troll
i'm not sure they're putting that much
time into it maybe maybe but i'm just
going to say based off of everything
that we've heard
all of the leaks all of the rumors just
kind of everything i'm going to say this
is 100
real in my personal opinion and i'm not
a vfx artist i'm just going to take
their word for it and the guy who said
it was deep fake said that his deep fake
was fake and that the original video was
real
you know he took the time to try to do
something but even these guys said right
away
they could tell that it was
that his
video was faked and they say that they
think this is real so
i'm gonna go ahead and say it's real
it's nice that we have like an actual
real vfx artist talking about this
saying that they believe it's real
because it just further backs up
everything that we've heard but let me
know what you guys think about this in
the comments down below
i'm happy with this um i think it's only
a matter of time until it's revealed
that uh toby
andrew
are both in the film but let me know
what you guys think in the comments down
below don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you can stay
updated on all the marvel and spider-man
videos don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof